Hi there.
Welcome to this LinkedIn lesson.
I'm Victoria and
I'm a project manager at Udacity.
In this lesson, we'll be covering
how to transform LinkedIn from yet
another tiresome job material into
a creative platform to tell your
professional story.
We'll focus on both the big themes and
the tiny steps to boost your
professional online presence.
Based on our experience and the research
we've done with hiring managers and
recruiters, we'll cover
the purpose of LinkedIn and
provide you with tips on how to use
the platform to your greatest advantage.
Specifically, this lesson will detail
the different components within
a LinkedIn profile, and
the best practices for each.
We'll also provide you with
a strategy to connect with others
within your network.
Don't have a Linked In profile or have
one and for less than excited about it.
By the end of this lesson, you will
have completed Stella LinkedIn profile.
You should also be feeling more
confident that your online presence
conveys an accurate depiction of your
professional experience and goals.
So, how do you currently feel
about your LinkedIn profile?
What is one thing you like about it and
one thing you'd like to change?
Feel free to post your
responses in the forum.
Ready?
Let's get started.